[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday November
5th in your video yesterday you asked if
I would discuss the political situation
in Pakistan while eating something that
isn't food I am of course happy to
accommodate that request while I
discussed the political situation in
Pakistan I'm going to attempt to eat 24
peeps pumpkins now I know what you're
saying you're saying wait a second peeps
pumpkins are food oh really
if they're food how come they don't
contain any nutrition heck for the
purposes of our story today we're going
to begin in 1988 Pakistan is holding its
first free election in a decade and the
winner of the election is a woman named
benazir bhutto the prime ministership of
pakistan went back and forth between
Bhutto and this guy named Sharif now
Sharif happens to be president in 1999
and because the government's kind of
corrupt a lot of people aren't happy
there's widespread rumors that there
might be a military takeover in Pakistan
which has happened plenty of times
before the head of the army is this guy
Pervez Musharraf who SAR flees the
country to go on vacation right and
while he's out of the country Sharif
announces that Musharraf is no longer
the head of the army so Musharraf gets
on a plane like a regular commercial
plane when he gets to Karachi Sharif the
Prime Minister says to the airport you
cannot let that plane land and the
airport like okay you're the Prime
Minister so Musharraf plane just keeps
circling right and Musharraf literally
like uses the air phone in the plane or
maybe he illegally used his cellphone I
don't know but he calls the army and
he's like hey guys can you take over the
airport in Karachi for me and they're
like yeah so they invade the Karachi
Airport take it over
moosh arse plane lands with like five
minutes of gas to spare these are going
down like butter
so pervez musharraf becomes the prime
minister of pakistan now it's 1999
Pakistan has just made itself a nuclear
power which made America mad and then
this unelected dictator general guy
becomes Prime Minister which is just
like so 1970s South America you know
we're not getting along well with
Pakistan at all ended on September 12
2001 all of a sudden pervez musharraf
good friend of ours now some people
would say that Musharraf has been
generally pretty cooperative with the
United States as far as terrorism goes
and that's true to an extent
but I would argue that the
radicalization of Pakistan would never
have even happened if it hadn't have
been for Musharraf example the last time
there were free elections in Pakistan in
the late 1990s radical Islamic political
parties won about 6% of the vote as I
recall now analysts say that they could
win up to 40% of a free vote now during
this time one of the few things that's
giving Pakistan from being an all-out
dictatorship is that Pakistan still has
a sort of quasi independent judiciary so
in early 2007 the Supreme Court made
Musharraf mad and he asked the leader of
the Supreme Court to resign and the
leader of the Supreme Court said no
thank you and this kind of symbolized
his general weakening and plus there had
been a lot of talk about elections and
so Bhutto and Sharif see this as their
opportunity to come out of exile back to
Pakistan and restore democracy or at the
very least become the new dictator so
Sharif flies in from Saudi Arabia last
month and he's met at the airport by the
army who tells him nicely that he should
either consider going back to Saudi
Arabia or consider dying in jail Sharif
needless to say don't like it I've been
waiting like 20 minutes to tell that
joke then Bhutto comes back from Dubai
to Pakistan and she is actually allowed
entrance back into the country although
she's almost assassinated on her way to
her house then Musharraf decides that
he's going to put most of the Supreme
Court under house arrest along with a
lot of the other top judges he also
decides to suspend the Constitution and
severely curtail freedom of press ah yes
I ate the peeps the first people to
protest the suspension of the
Constitution and the removal of these
judges all of Pakistan's lawyers Hank
how screwed up is the world when
warriors hold the moral high ground so
Hank that's the news from Pakistan I
never thought I'd say this in my life
but go lawyers I'll see you tomorrow